I'm a little nervous to be down this
first time at all how personally I'm
gonna make this the best night of your
life
we're talking about hosting the ACM
award show right that promo of y'all's
hysterical she wrote it if you have any
problem you just just look at me yes
ma'am appearance
I know these are some really big smiles
she just turned her back and just grabs
my arms ago you just put them right here
and I go no I can't you know I was like
No And we were laughing so hard we were
just joking about it because you better
take him you got Carl and you guys yeah
I don't think about them
mic drop I wanted to shine tonight did I
make it yes Dolly Parton is back for the
second year in a row hosting the ACM
Awards Thursday on Prime video and Garth
Brooks is splitting the job with her
Kane Brown Ed Sheeran Miranda Lambert
and Keith Urban are some of the Stars
performing at country music's party of
the Year Morgan Wallen just dropped out
due to vocal fold trauma and today had
to cancel the next six weeks of shows to
go on mandatory vocal rest but Dolly's
got a surprise it involves a preview of
her first ever Rock album Rockstar which
is out November 17th Miley Cyrus pink
Stevie Nicks and lizzo are just some of
the Superstar collabs
well I am doing my first single from my
rock album on the ACM it's going to be a
huge big production it's going to have
fire and smoke and all the rock and roll
things any chance you can break us off
some of those lyrics Dolly oh yeah it
says liar liar the world's on fire what
you gonna do when it all burns down that
just happened are you gonna get this one
here to rock out with you and maybe do a
little dude I'm gonna do that either he
says he's not going to sleep I've never
hosted in my life I'm just trying to
survive okay
can't help my eyes are navigating
towards your arm is this fresh ink this
is uh probably in the last six months I
ended up
getting a small one it's a three-quarter
sleeve chest and back if you consider
that small Garth yeah it's a it's just a
tribute to the women in my life so my
three daughters my mom's on my shoulders
and then my sheerwood's on my heart
where am I going to be well Dolly's
gonna go right there on the other arm
with a heart and an arrow through it
foreign